quelques chroniqueurs surprise va faire
son arrivée dans les flingueurs du paf
mais là ils tentaient leurs mots mathieu
dans mon nom alors je veux dire aux gens
vous enlève un point pourquoi parce que
vous vous reculez vous foutez de ma
gueule ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
tout à fait honnête j'adore le foot de
votre gueule
fait avancer tous les chevaux sur celui
de m
tous les chevaux sous le choc solide b
line up saw libanité mercer chef
aujourd'hui fait reculer encore benhaim
notre ère avec cadeaux demain je dois y
aller chercher demain matin matthieu
delormeau oui c'est bien mathieu
delormeau leader matthieu delormeau
d'ailleurs il en coulisses il est où
mathieu qu'on voit ça alors gardez le
mathieu
c'est vrai très bien ça va mon chéri
d'amour
sa maman chérie alors es tu viens nous
rejoindre tout à l'heure je suis très
content de te voir
je sais on s'est vus tous les deux on a
été prendre un verre on m'a toujours
prendre des airs
de michel visio là il m'a michel vision
[Applaudissements]
vous
je suis désolé âgées trucks enemis y est
les amis sa mère cet homme est retourné
vers le
bio c'est fabrice vision est très bon je
suis très contente de voir tout à
l'heure à ces gentils et on va pas se
mentir à tous les deux on s'est dit des
choses et tous les deux cc voilà c'est
on sait on sait jamais fâchés de mathieu
et moi pour vous le sachiez ah non il il
a dit exactement ce qu'il a fait mathieu
il a fait une année sabbatique et on
s'est rappelé l'a dit tiens j'ai envie
de g j'ai envie de rigoler j'ai envie
d'en et de débattre surtout exactement
après j'ai pris une année sabbatique je
voulais voyager bon il convient donc
de taille sinon
[Applaudissements]
c'est un petit problème de timing
problème de taille mais qui sentent les
choses
c'est l'eau tout va bien je suis très en
forme on s'est vu cet été ça me fait
très plaisir ça fait plaisir de voir
toute la bande
l'anniversaire de beinheim bien sûr de
vous rejoindre un plateau et je voulais
dire ça s'est passé très simplement
c'est ma plume ou c'est mon abo wind qui
verrait m'a dit ouais c'est ça y est
j'ai pas pu faire mon tour du monde
voilà donc voilà j'ai envie de jouer
envie de revenir je suis pas très bien
battus revient et puis voilà est donc là
il va faire les flingueurs du paf tout à
l'heure il sera en débat est là il va
être très très bon t'as vu que bien
entouré tout à l'heure je vais avoir une
époque quand même apprendre les prénoms
des mecs qui moi est avec toi mais je
suis désolé c'est parce que je
connaissais pas mais j'ai vu jean tout à
l'heure dans l'est là que je vois là et
je connaissais pas les autres sur koné
bomba mais non mais c'est parce qu'avant
il y avait des gens connus et tout donc
là c'est plus compliqué pour moi mais
ces coûts non mais non
j'ai dit que je le connais pas c'est bon
il est bien de retour à tout à l'heure
[Applaudissements]